wie viele ja vielleicht wissen aus der
dir ein oder andere der mich jetzt nicht
kennt setze ich mich seit vielen Jahren
für gegen Missstände in unserem Land ein
und bin für viele ein Sprachrohr
Millionen Menschen hör mir zu und fühlen
sich durch das was ich sage auch wenn
ich jetzt oder unkonventionell sage
verstanden und abgeholt ich kriege sehr
viele E-Mails und ich habe jetzt hier
einfach mal ein paar Ausschnitte dazu
mitgebracht ich nehme jetzt immer die
die ich am wirklich auch am warnendsten
für uns alle finden sollte Vater mit
einem Monatseinkommen von 2200 € netto
schreibt wir sind vier Personen im
Haushalt meine Frau arbeitet auch
Teilzeit wie ich ich arbeite fast jeden
Tag 24 Stunden meine Familie und ich
haben natürlich Angst vor dem was
passiert ich kann noch nicht mal einen
Ausflug von 410 € leisten für meinen
Sohn also einen so einen Klassenausflug
ja ich weiß nicht mehr weiter manchmal
habe ich gedacht mein Leben zu beenden
doch ich kann meine Familie nicht im
Stich lassen wenn wir diese Weg so
weitergehen mit einer Politik die nur
ihren Interessen und Ideologien folgt
werden wir noch nie da gewesene Suizid
Zahlen haben bis hin das familienv oder
auch Mütter die Familie vielleicht mit
in den Tod nehmen das sind und ich
kriege hunderte von so einem E-Mails
ganz besonders nach Auftritten bei euch
bekomme ich solche Dinge auch in euren
Kommentaren tausende von Zuschriften die
da drin stehen das ist der tägliche die
tägliche Traurigkeit die tägliche
Realität und da kam ich so viele ich
kann hier einige davon Vorlesen die
wirklich schlimm sind alle deine
körperlicher Behinderter Vater von
dreijährigen Sohn schreibt ich habe seit
einem Monat nichts Warmes mehr gegessen
es wird täglich nicht mehr als ein
Brötchen und wasche mich nur noch mit
dem Lappen am Waschbecken um Kosten zu
sparen damit mein Sohn der drei Jahre
ist kein Hunger mehr leidet sich auf
letztens gemacht in grün und hier ist
das ganze Ding noch mal orange lieber
Herr Kretschmer lieber Steinmeier lieber
Bundesregierung steckt euch eure
Waschlappen sonst vorhanden und sorgt
dafür dass die Menschen in unserem Land
solche Dinge nicht erleiden müssen
solche Schmerzen und solche leiden nicht
erfahren müssen das kann nicht sein dass
wir in unserem reichen Land nicht dafür
schaffen dass unsere Bürger leben wollen
und vor allen Dingen auch existieren
können wir verschenken Geld in aller
Welt und bei uns leiden Menschen und ihr
baut euren Kanzler trotz Bau eure
potenzverlängerung da weiter schämt ihr
euch nicht in Grund den Boden ich kann
mich gar nicht so viel Fremdschäden und
im Strahl kotzen wenn ich das alles sehe
und dieser Verzweiflung hier höre und
das macht mich wütend
es schneide das natürlich ihr
schockierende Beispiele haben sie die
Menschen auch getroffen also es ist sie
schreiben mir manchmal ja auch anonym
weil sie ja nicht gewissen manche halten
mit Namen
verifizieren
ist ja die E-Mail-Adresse oft doch
Telefonnummer das ist ja teilweise ja so
also dass oft steht ja auch dabei wir
danken Ihnen dass Sie für uns sprechen
oder das was sie sagen in der Art der
Markt für den ein oder anderen jetzt für
sie hat vielleicht ein bisschen kurios
sein wie ich spreche aber viele Menschen
spüren halt bei mir diese Wut diese Wut
jetzt betrifft nicht nicht vielleicht
wie jeden von denen weil ich vielleicht
in einem gesellschaftlichen anderen
Positionen vielleicht sein mag aber egal
wie gut es mir geht oder wie schlecht es
mir geht es ist meine Aufgabe und meine
Pflicht als Vorbild für Millionen von
Menschen und als Bürger und Vater an
diesem Land auch für die Menschen die
Stimme zu erheben den nicht so gut
gestellt sind und die den schwächer geht
ich frage mich bloß ich bin nicht
Innenminister nicht Bundeskanzler und
auch sonst niemand von den Würdenträgern
die dafür die Kohle bekommen sondern ihr
bekommt ihre Forderung an die
Würdenträger wie Sie sehen erstmal fängt
man in der Krise an seinen Charakter zu
überweisen das hat der beste ever gesagt
ja so und ich würde noch mal anfangen
bei unseren Herrn der jeden Tag vergisst
wahrscheinlich auch wieder heißt dass er
anfängt zu sagen also in so einer Krise
können wir nicht für 777 Millionen Euro
den Kanzler Bau weitermachen das brauche
ich nicht wir stoppen Ding ja auch wenn
die Bundesregierung da fordert
angefangen hat wird man Signalen Zeichen
und dann sollte man vielleicht vor sie
ja vorsichtiger mit dem Geld was man so
verteilt auf der ganzen Welt und für
Dinge ein bisschen überlegen bietet sich
für die Menschen anfühlt die halt solche
Dinge da schreiben die die kleinsten
Dinge nicht mehr machen können man
sollte von seiner Wolke 7 aus seiner
Wand blitzblase mal rauskommen und
einfach mal zwischen die Bürger also zum
lösungsamt sie sind also für Höheres
Hartz IV für höhere Grundsicherung für
Höheres aufstocken das würden sie
fordern dass mehr Geld an die Bürger
ausgeschüttet ich glaube es wäre schon
mal glaube ich wichtig dass man halt
guckt so wie ich die Politiker auch
gemacht haben sie haben sich ja zum
Beispiel Europaparlament um die
Inflationsrate ihre Gehälter erhöht ja
also wenn man das mal so sieht oder sich
überhaupt ihre transfert es wäre doch
schon mal wichtig dass wir natürlich
auch das Ausgleich natürlich muss man
gucken wenn es sollte schon noch wichtig
in unserem Land sein dass es sich lohnt
arbeiten zu gehen denn wenn ich jetzt
höre dass bestimmte Bürgergeld auf
einmal so laufen sollen dass die Leute
sagen bin ich bekloppt und soll ich noch
arbeiten gehen die bezahlen mein Strom
mein Gas meine Miete da geht jeder der
Arbeitgeber hat weniger dann haben wir
beide Leute die ja nicht mehr arbeiten
gehen das darf auch nicht sein gibt's
das Aufstocken beispielsweise damit das
schon auf einem Niveau bleibt das
arbeiten gehen und das Bürgergeld okay
also wir müssen versuchen aufzufangen
und selbst wenn genau ich kann mich
nicht als als als als oberste
Staatsoberhaupt hinstellen eine große
Ansprache halten wo übrigens kein
bundesregierungsmitglied anwesend ist
wie erbärmlich und peinlich und dann
sagen wir müssen uns auf harte raue
Jahre ein einstellen und selber aber
keine Opfer und Entbehrung bringen große
Töne drücken schmucken und sich Heuchler
sich dahin stellen und von uns
Entbehrung erwarten und selber nicht
hingehen bitte Herr Steinmeier lassen
Sie uns gemeinsam zu diesen Menschen
gehen und wenn Sie schon dabei kein Geld
Zeit zu verschenken wie wäre es denn mal
ein bisschen Geld für Aathal was nämlich
da brach liegt und wo die Menschen bis
heute nicht bekommen haben wo sie alle
größeren tone gespuckt haben wie es da
war habe so Fotos gemacht jetzt ist für
alle Dieter nur für die Menschen in
unserem Land nicht zumindestens nicht so
spürbar dass sie nicht diese Dinger
bekommen und der traurig ist ich glaube
dass sie schon so verzweifelt sind dass
sie ja nicht mehr Familienministerin und
soweit Anschreiben sondern eher die
Bild-Zeitung oder mich oder andere
Organisation weil sie den schon lange
nicht mehr vertrauen
wie steht es um die Armut in unserem
Land naja gut das Problem ist wir waren
eine Industriegesellschaft denn in der
Industriegesellschaft ist die Fähigkeit
der abhängig Beschäftigten ihre
Interessen zur Geltung zu bringen sich
zu organisieren sehr viel größer als in
einer Dienstleistungsgesellschaft
insofern fand ich das
grundsätzlich eine bemerkenswerte
Leistung des ersten und zweiten
Kabinetts Schröder Fischer dass sie im
Unterschied zu dem englischen
Entwicklungsweg Maggie Thatcher
sozusagen voll
Dienstleistungsgesellschaft zu gehen
versucht haben industrielle Kerne bei
uns aufrecht zu erhalten man kann über
die harzreformen ja streiten ob das in
dieser Hinsicht klug war oder weniger
klug war jedenfalls das war die Absicht
dabei und das kann man sagen ist
sozusagen ein ursozialdemokratisches
anlegen
nun zeigt sich aber natürlich in der
internationalen Konkurrenz
Globalisierung mit wem auch immer ist es
nicht so leicht
Industrie aufrecht zu erhalten
jedenfalls dann wenn die Produkte die
man herstellt viel zu teuer sind um sich
auf dem Weltmarkt behaupten zu können
und insofern würde ich Unterschied zu
Herrn Stahl eher da ansetzen zu
überlegen in welcher Weise sind wir in
der Lage auch die Politik in der Lage
gesellschaftliche Verhältnisse zu
schaffen in denen entsprechende
Arbeitsmöglichkeiten für die Leute da
sind so dass Sie also letzten Endes
nicht von Wohltaten von wem auch immer
dem Staat oder
Herr Steinmeier persönlich und der Leim
er man kennt ja sozusagen diese Vorgänge
wo Politiker sich gerne inszenieren
unter den Bedürftigen unter dem
Betroffenen der Leimer oder mit
Steuergeldern Weihnachtsmann Spielen der
Weihnachtsmann Spielen von mir aus auch
das
Problem ist es muss den hinterher
natürlich alles vernünftig organisiert
werden und rechtlich so gefasst werden
das ist nicht bei den falschen ankommt
und wir haben ja in den letzten Jahren
oft genug also in der Frage der Pandemie
etwa erlebt dass schlampiggemachte
Gesetze Ausführungsbestimmungen dazu
führen das Geld quasi rausgeschmissen
worden es irgendwo hin in dunklen
Kanälen versickert und der Leim ja das
ist sicherlich mit einer der Gründe
warum man nicht im Einzelfall helfen
kann aus der Politik was ist eher eine
Sache der caritativen Organisationen
sondern dass man Rahmenbedingungen
schaffen muss in denen die Menschen die
Chance haben ein selbstbestimmtes Leben
zu führen indem sie auch die Anerkennung
für sich bekommen nicht ich bin abhängig
ich muss andere um etwas bitten sondern
ich selber schaffe das mich aus dem
Dreck herauszuarbeiten
ich finde sie sind da gar nicht so
auseinander denn was ich auch nicht mehr
hören kann ist diese ich meine gut bin
natürlich privilegierter und so aber
trotzdem kann ich es nicht mehr hören
dieses ewige müssten den Gürtel enger
schneiden langsamer fahren auf der
Autobahn um Sprit zu sparen okay Heizung
runter drehen meint wegen ist ja auch
okay also all diese Maßnahmen gut aber
ohne diese Gänge Leib bitte aber vor
allen Dingens doch um folgendes und sie
haben es erwähnt wir sind durch diese
Reform immer noch ein Land mit den
größten industriellen Kernen in
Deutschland bis jetzt und wir haben
einen Wirtschafts- und klimaminister
aber bitte in dieser Reihenfolge
Wirtschaft und Klima und vielleicht ist
es mal Zeit sich um die Wirtschaft zu
kümmern und zu gucken wie kann ich es
schaffen dass ich dass ich Unternehmen
davon abhalte nach China zu gehen wie
jetzt BASF dass ich es gibt verlockende
Angebote auch aus den USA für viele
viele Unternehmen wo Unternehmen weniger
Steuern zahlen weniger Energiepreise
bezahlen und dergleichen sich damit
darum zu kümmern also diese
industriellen Kerne ist ja immer noch
gibt in Europa gerade in Deutschland zu
bewahren um den Menschen eben auch
Arbeit zu geben und sie eben nicht in
Hartz IV zu bringen oder das Bürgergeld
zu kassieren der sich übrigens die genau
die gleichen Probleme und dann geht sie
auch weiter Gründerin Gründer haben
jetzt gerade im Finanzminister
geschrieben haben gesagt wo sind denn
hier die Innovation wo sind die
Beteiligungsmöglichkeiten er sagt ja ich
kümmere mich darum aber all das hören
wir doch schon lange wo ist der
Bürokratieabbau den wir seit 20 Jahren
brauchen wo die wirkliche
ganztagsschulbetreuung wo gibt es die
Chancengleichheit mittlerweile in den
Schulen für Kinder gibt es doch auch
nicht mehr
also es gibt einen wirklich Haufen von
Problemen aber für mich fängt es an in
der Wirtschaft und darum tatsächlich
sich um die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit und die
Möglichkeit zu kümmern vom Steuerrecht
hin bis zur Bürgerbeteiligung auch in
Unternehmen an gewinnen auch
entsprechend dann auch und da gibt es
noch ganz viel zu tun Wirtschaft nicht
als Feind zu sehen sondern als das was
Menschen in die Möglichkeit versetzen
gutes Einkommen zu haben das wünsche ich
mir Herr Gräber ist vielleicht Schuld
die Anspruchshaltung der Staat wird es
schon richten nicht erst in der
corona-pandemie wurde es ja sehr auf den
Staat alles ausgelegt der Start der
starke Start der aber natürlich nicht
immer zielgerichtet agiert ich glaube es
ist in Deutschland traditionell bei uns
und von der SPD entschuldigung wenn ich
ihre Partei da jetzt in Haftung nehme
aber speziell von der SPD ist schon
dieses der kümmernde Staat der der Vater
Staat der sich um alle Probleme kümmert
was auch in Deutschland glaube ich
vieles auch befriedet hat also wir leben
Gott sei immer noch in einem Land wo
auch die sozialen
Konflikte natürlich da sind weil es sich
natürlich auseinander entwickelt aber
wenn man in in Länder wie wie die USA
oder sowas guckt wo das viel viel
stärker auseinander geht da kann man ja
auch froh sein dass es bei uns eben
nicht so ist trotzdem steckt dahinter
was was man sich auch leisten können
muss und diesen Sozialstaat den wir bei
uns haben den auch jeder
selbstverständlich in Anspruch nimmt und
sofort dann wenn es wirtschaftliche
Probleme gibt muss der Staat die
Kaufhäuser retten er muss er muss den
die Energiekosten jetzt drücken er muss
bei Corona muss er die Lockdown Ausfälle
finanzieren das Geld muss ja auch
irgendwo herkommen und da kommen wir zu
dem Punkt der der Wirtschaft und der
Industrie wir sind gerade mittendrin in
einer hochgefährlichen Phase wo wir
dabei sind den Kern unseres Wohlstands
zu verlieren und zwar nicht nur wie bei
vergangenen Krisen mal durch den Tal zu
gehen dann geht es wieder aufwärts nee
wir sind dabei dass wir wirklich was
eigentlich was kaputt machen was in
Jahrzehnten nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
hier aufgebaut wurde und da habe ich
große Sorgen dafür und deswegen nehme
ich auch Herrn Habeck da kommen wir
später sein agieren in diesem speziellen
Segment der Energiepolitik was aber ein
sehr wichtiges ist nämlich ihm da auch
auch sehr sehr übel ich halte das für
hoch hoch gefährlich was was die
Bundesregierung da gerade treibt wenn
wir noch einmal bei der anfangsthese von
Herrn Stahl bleiben hätte ich noch eine
Frage an Sie wieso funktioniert es denn
nicht wir sind ja einer Meinung mit der
Anspruchshaltung und dem Staat aber
Kinderarmut zu bekämpfen das hat sich ja
nicht nur die SPD sondern eigentlich
alle Parteien immer auf die Fahne
eigentlich geschrieben warum
funktioniert das nicht wirklich und das
nicht erst seit fünf Jahren sollen ja
eigentlich seit Jahrzehnten ist daher
keine große Verbesserung eingetreten
naja ich meine Sozialwissenschaftler
könnte ich jetzt natürlich sagen das hat
auch was mit den veränderten
Lebensentwürfen von Menschen zu tun also
dem Wachstum der Anzahl der
Alleinerziehenden bei denen natürlich
die materiellen Probleme eskalieren
doch den 50er 60er 70er Jahren war halt
die zwei elternfamilie der Regelfall
schauen Sie sich bestimmten Bereichen
die Veränderung das ja der Lebensführung
an dann bekommen sie natürlich schon
eine Vorstellung davon wie so etwas auch
passiert wie sich so etwas entwickelt
nun versteht man dafür ein Problem
nämlich zu sagen es ist die freie
Entscheidung eines jeden Menschen aber
ein Kind haben will oder nicht und ob er
mit einem Vater oder dieser Mutter
zusammenleben will oder nicht
jetzt kommt aber das Problem hinzu dass
in gewisser Hinsicht ja auch Ihr Problem
war in der Frage Bürgergeld naja da gibt
es aber dann auch welche die die
sozialen Netze sozusagen ausnutzen mir
ist gut innerlich als unsere Tochter
Handball gespielt hat der hat ziemlich
gut Handball gespielt
da gab es Eltern drumherum die waren
jünger als ich ja gehört es ja so
Handwerker waren alle arbeitslos im
Wedding und alle arbeitslos haben aber
natürlich alle schwarz gearbeitet nicht
dann haben sich sozusagen eine
unterhalten was sie für Ansprüche an den
Staat haben und der Leim mehr und so
eine sehr einfache Frau die aus dem
Osten Berlins kamen und ich will man
glaube ich die einzigen die in normalen
Beschäftigungsverhältnissen waren und
wir soll das eigentlich bezahlen nicht
dann habe ich die angeguckt und habe
mich selber angeguckt und habe gesagt ja
okay wir
das heißt dieses Problem er taucht
natürlich in vielen Zusammenhängen auf
und natürlich
was weiß ich kann der Staat da nicht
jedem hinterher schnüffeln und
herausbekommen dass der natürlich als
Klempner oder Fliesenleger oder was auch
immer
ein Vielfaches verdient dass er
obendrein nicht versteuert und für das
er also auch keine Sozialleistungen
abführt und der Leimer
das heißt eine funktionierende
Demokratie als eine freiheitliche
Gesellschaft ist auf ein gewisses Ethos
bei den Menschen angewiesen das heißt
jetzt nicht dass man das bei jedem
unterstellen kann aber man muss letzten
Endes unterstellen können dass
tendenziell 80 bis 90 Prozent so ticken
und ist das der Fall dann wächst auch
die Bereitschaft zu helfen welcher Weise
auch immer individuell indem ich was
weiß ich
irgendwelche Gelder in die Kirche gebe
oder indem ich in jedem Fall nur
anständige Steuererklärung abgeben und
ich versuche sozusagen mich da irgendwo
rauszudrücken hat man aber das Gefühl
naja sozusagen wir finanzieren damit
einen Teil der Gesellschaft der keine
Lust hat zu arbeiten dann ist schlecht
hier würde ich einmal noch mal an Herrn
Stahl zurückgeben ist es so dass 80 bis
90 Prozent so ticken ist es dass
Menschenbild was sie teilen
dass sie 80 Prozent habe ich jetzt
richtig verstanden der Menschen den
etwas haben also dass sie arbeiten
wollen um gemeint etwas zuzutragen also
wenn ich jetzt wirklich mein Gefühl dass
man sagen würde würde ich mich freuen
wenn es so wäre ich denke ich auch ich
glaube es nicht ja ich glaube es leider
nicht weil ich glaube durch das was
viele Jahre bei uns versäumt wurde
vorgelebt wurde und auch gemacht wurde
das ist einfach teilweise auch viel zu
einfach gemacht wird übrigens jetzt
nicht nur auch auch diese auch deswegen
sage ich das immer wieder und ich komme
kommen aus Berlin-Neukölln ich bin also
viel mit migrationsgrund aufgewachsen
und ich habe viele Freunde mit
Migrationshintergrund aber ich sehe
natürlich auch so ein bisschen wenn man
das so guckt jemand kommt hier in unser
Land wird sofort aufgefangen ja da er
soll integriert werden oft passiert das
gar nicht es man wird überlässt sie
teilweise sich selbst und dann bleiben
sie da irgendwo hängen so und wenn man
wenn man sich das so anschaut dann dann
hat das natürlich auf andere auch eine
Wirkung warum soll ich arbeiten gehen
wenn der oder der es nicht tut und wenn
man sich das jetzt wirklich anguckt ich
habe da das letzte wieder mit jemandem
gesprochen ich habe mal durchgerechnet
für jemand der Bürgergeld bekommt mit
allem drum und dran ich habe vielleicht
und ich muss jeden Tag arbeiten gehen
jeden Benzin schon unterwegs ich habe
vielleicht 150 € mehr na warum soll ich
mitmachen und dann dann zahlen Sie den
noch egal ob das ob der 500 € Gas sind
warum und das ist der absolut falsche
Anreiz und deswegen 80% in Ehren also
wenn wir wenn wir bei 50 60 % wären dann
würde ich mich freuen weil das
beschreibt natürlich den schwierigen
Zustand unserer Gesellschaft in diese 80
bis 90% ist die Voraussetzung
funktioniert und wenn es drunter fällt
dann haben wir ein Problem
es kommt natürlich auch so weil Menschen
orientieren sich nach Vorbildern und
wenn die Vorbilder keine Leitbilder mehr
sind und mir die Bürger das Gefühl haben
von bestimmten Politikern oder von
bestimmten Teilen der Regierung
verarscht zu werden dann ist der Anreiz
das auch wirklich dem Land etwas zu
geben irgendwie auch nicht mehr da ich
höre so eine Lethargie die Menschen
vertrauen dieser Politik nicht mehr
nicht allen vielleicht aber vielen
großen Teilen der Regierung und sie
sprachen ist ja nur von unseren
Wirtschaftsminister der schon haben Sie
die perfekte moderationsüber leiden hier
sind ein paar vielen Dank